the biggest reason people are confused
is they're bringing their internet brain
to the blockchain thus they can't
understand that you can own something
digital which is why that big joke well
i'm just gonna right click and save it
well that's an internet function it
doesn't work on the blockchain
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
well yeah really good excited me too
my dad
sasha okay
[Music]
[Applause]
we've yeah been aware of qr technology
for 20 years it took covid to get people
to actually use it yeah
so i think everybody here will know how
to use this i just want you to see how
frictionless this is this is a poep so
it's not full web 3. i would call this
web 2.5 you take this photo and you'll
have a digital asset if you put in your
email in about five seconds now having a
digital asset
might be a frictionless kind of
experience that takes one minute that
might spur
ideas that you might bring to your
organizations so we wanted to just do
that so i hope you do that and i hope it
starts your journey
rolex it's gary uh big shout out big
love to ukraine i hope we get to meet my
friend very nice to see you take care
alex come on question i'm a photographer
i've sold many nfts but where would you
recommend me to you know to sell my
stuff with which platform which one i
believe
you know what i mean my friend there's
no reason not to be on foundation and
wearable and open sea why would you
create friction
it was just like when people used to ask
me gary what social network should i
produce on them like all of them if
you're trying to sell something why
would you create friction for someone
the only reason you're seeing that now
is the early artists are being artists
got it they're being cute
what you did was unparalleled history is
going to look back at you and smile at
you as one of the key voices
thank you very much
thank you brother hands down thank you
for saying that what is the biggest
challenge for the nft marketplace in the
next couple years
the challenge of time and getting kind
of the stink off of the you know bad
behavior of the gold rush
those two things stand out what's your
definition of creativity you can be
creative in any medium you want to be
whether it comes from being creative and
innovative in your business
or making your art or
designing clothes or just the way that
you present yourself to the world
and then you know with web3 and these
metaverses you can be creative in ways
that are not even possible in the
physical world
i like it
[Music]
awesome
thank you very much
[Music]
uh
this is a good room hi hi i'm hilah
what's happening i'm gary hi hi
how are you guys doing how's can
treating y'all so far so good hannah
yeah
nfts yes theme of the week we just did
that talk yep are you guys like the king
queen can we like she's definitely the
queen i'm not sure what i am maybe the
the jester but uh she is definitely the
queen okay what's the skepticism what
how are you still trying what are people
still not getting about nfts
from my perspective it's that they don't
understand that it's on the blockchain
and not the internet the real reality is
people used to make fun of their parents
for not having email for not having
social media for not having a smartphone
the big reality is most people have
become their parents and they're going
to have to understand that truth this is
a good team currently i see why you guys
teamed up nice job good running thank
you have a good time
bye nice you're going to find your real
roommate now that's right
i think we'll go back to the boat okay
let's go
now
it's funny that you guys brought up
roblox i was in romania
a couple days ago and
and i i asked the audience i said do you
understand that between minecraft roblox
madden and 2k points to power up candy
crush everybody under 15
is only being trained into buying things
that are digital versus buying things
that are physical only when
somebody who's 13 today
is literally 23 in 10 years it goes like
this right and they become the market
and
i i don't even know how it's a debate to
be honest and so consumer behavior does
not map to wall street or crypto prices
and and i think that's where the
conversation starts and ends
welcome everybody to can um
most importantly just thank you because
i know you have unlimited unlimited
options of where you're going to spend
your time in this very short week and so
let there be no confusion we are
substantially humbled by you choosing to
be with us um and uh i want to thank
paris for the incredible uh keynote that
we just gave i thought you were amazing
on stage and
as someone who fancies himself and being
underrated at times um
it's it's it's always very fun for me to
see
others navigate the world and be
underrated for whatever their
circumstances are
i find you to be one of those people and
so i really appreciated sharing the
stage with you and uh hope you have a
great time and thank you for being here
cheers
why does somebody really buy an andy
warhol for a lot of people they love
andy and it's but for a lot of people
they buy it to put in their wall and
when they're having dinner parties or
business meetings or friends over
they're like my warhol how many people
could actually see that warhol
for that reason 30 250
whereas where it's going and it's been
proven out already and this was early
talk and that's exactly what's happening
a lot of the reason people are buying is
to flex it's no different than having
why did sneakers become big people flex
their sneakers i was literally just
walking up here and somebody had a very
rare nike pair he was walking out i said
nice kicks he was pumped that's why he
bought him he bought him for somebody to
say that to him
and that's exactly what's happening with
nfts at scale people will buy it because
they're going to flex and a lot of
people like
when they were arguing with me they're
like i don't care about a digital asset
i remember my one friend
who really went off he goes i just this
is the stupidest [ __ ] i ever heard i
said brother you called me six months
ago and asked me to get you a blue check
mark on instagram i go that's a digital
asset and that's where it flipped for
him he understood that it's just
communication let's just think about
this space always
you know every time you
since you left i cross
like something is missing ain't been the
same i been hurting this got me up in my
feelings i know you watching so i pray
and i just hope that you listen i wanna
say that i miss you
hey just know that i ain't forget you
know
[Music]
that's all i got the crab like
everything that is wrong at vaynermedia
is 100 my fault why take on that
accountability that's the price of entry
to be a ceo